foreign
the resistance training Revolution uh
we're having a conversation about on the
airplane and just the folks that travel
with me were like what what right and
the second is you've been working with
Trainers for years and so you we talked
about earlier getting behind like the
the meal plan and the weight loss why
are people struggling the way they're
struggling yeah right and so let me
start off this way
um what happened
what happened to the fitness and the
diet like what happened because the more
I'm learning the simpler it's getting
but I consider myself somebody who's up
on the science knows what I'm talking
about and dude I was so I was so lost at
sea man what happened yeah so you could
say it's both very simple and very
complex and also the way that we've
tried to tackle the problem has come
from the wrong angle completely which is
why we failed okay uh so terribly so
let's start with the I guess the Obesity
or poor health epidemic
um in in a nutshell or environment
changed far faster than our ability to
develop
um I guess guidelines or structures or
behaviors around that new environment
and so the the result of which has been
poor health but to be more specific
um I know in the 80s so I'm I'm you know
I remember I'm old enough to remember
you know obesity being blamed on fat and
then it got blamed on carbohydrates and
you know who knows what they're gonna
blame out next maybe protein
um but you know so I'm old enough to
remember that and also old enough to see
how they were wrong on all of that
really what a lot of it has to do with
um and poor health is quite complex but
obesity a lot has to do with just the
consumption of heavily processed foods
okay and it's not that these foods are
inherently unhealthy although many of
them are
it's that these foods are engineered uh
to make us overeat and there's some
really really good studies on this so if
you like looking at data and studies or
some excellent studies done on heavily
processed foods where they take groups
of people and one of the challenges with
nutrition studies or Diet studies is a
lot of them are observational yeah or
you know they have to come in and kind
of report and how many tomatoes did you
have last year yeah it's super it's
super inaccurate but these studies were
really good because they were controlled
actually took people put them in a lab
and they said okay you group over here
you have unlimited access to whole
Natural Foods whole Natural Foods being
foods with like one or two ingredients
like bananas apples steak you know that
kind of stuff and then the other groups
like okay you guys have unlimited access
to heavily processed food so these are
foods that are in wrappers and boxes
things with long shelf life and they
actually even exactly and they and they
actually even
controlled the macro content so it's
like similar proteins fats and carbs
some of the proteins fats and carbs they
had them stay in those rooms for a while
and absorb them and then they switched
groups which is I love this part they
took this group put them in this room
took this group put them in that room
and what they found on average is that
people consume about five to six hundred
more calories a day when they heavily
process foods and that's again because
these foods are engineered to make us
over and if you look at if you really
want to put your finger on the main
culprit although like I said it's
complex if you want to put your finger
on the main culprit if you look at the
the predominance of heavily processed
foods in the American diet it starts off
very small but then it rapidly becomes a
majority of our diet you'll see that it
almost mirrors the Obesity epidemic you
just lay that map right on top of the
other one and you'll see that really
almost starts to mirror so to give
another good example
um of kind of what I'm talking about
um we had um Chris Kresser on the show a
few years ago and he gave this wonderful
analogy and I use it all the time now
and he said look if I took
five boiled plain potatoes I just boil
them in water give them to you no salt
no butter and said here eat all these
you probably wouldn't be able to do it
after about two potatoes you'd gag and
you'd get what's called pallet fatigue
but if I gave you a large family-sized
bag of Lay's potato chips which contains
roughly four to five potatoes you could
probably eat them all you could crush it
that's right yeah and so what's happened
is is all the research and development
that's gone into heavily processed foods
the vast majority that goes into
understanding and hacking how to get us
to eat more of these Foods it sells more
product but what it's done is it's
hijacked our systems of satiety and so
there's this belief that humans are
eating machines if you just put food in
front of us we'll just eat until we die
that's not that's not really true we do
have
um satiety that kicks in we do get
palate fatigue right we've all
experienced this we eat dinner you're
full I can't eat any more than they
bring out dessert all of a sudden you
feel like you can my kids call it uh my
dessert stomach is is doing great right
now right so and and this is this is a
very interesting phenomenon we have this
so we can actually so our bodies will
tell us to stop eating because
evolutionarily speaking it was bad to
overeat just like now just like it was
back then
um and there's lots of reasons right you
could overeat poor digestion you would
have died geez you got diarrhea a
thousand years ago who knows it that
might have been in your life right so so
but again these foods have hijacked
those and so when you eat a lot of these
Foods I mean you can apply discipline
you could try to like no I'm not gonna
eat any more but it's it's it's it's
it's almost a losing it's it is a losing
battle it really is how do we get from
that to blaming the consumer oh because
because the consumer does I mean I do
have some responsibility not eating
those chips and at the same time man I'm
fighting a whole bunch of scientists who
have like engineered it to make me not
one of them I am not blaming the
producers because they're a market
they're just giving us more what we want
okay okay and we're just feeling a gap
and markets are really good at that okay
they'll give us what we want and what do
we want convenience and we want the
hedonistic pleasure from the food we
want that that feeling so we got it yeah
um how do we how do we get that
responsibility well first we have to
become aware we have to become aware
that look these Foods
my body perceives them different than
other Foods yeah I'll give you a an
interest like really really effective
tip that I use with clients and it took
me a few years to kind of figure this
out so early in my career I wasn't a
great trainer and later on I became a
good trainer because I didn't do a good
job and I really had to figure out yeah
reps right what it took to do well and
early in my career I would do things
like hey Mrs Johnson I want you to cut
your calories by 500 calories and I'd
have her track and do all that stuff and
so like every day here's your calorie
Target and just do this and you'll get
great results well that didn't work uh
long term it never does later on what I
would do is I'd tell clients hey eat as
much as you want eat until you're
satisfied just avoid heavily processed
foods and they'd say okay and they would
get the same results as if they cut the
500 calories and it was again because
our bodies will eat more or less what's
appropriate when we remove those types
of foods out of our diet and that's just
one piece and there's a lot more that
goes into this our approach towards
weight loss has been all wrong both
mechanistically
but the big issue is that we're view we
we tend to view humans as like robots
you plug in the numbers and you'll get
the result and I did this as a trainer
oh you want to lose weight here's your
meal plan here's your workout just
follow this and you're going to be
totally fine as though weight loss is uh
solely due to a lack of correct
information it it it it doesn't work
data right yeah I mean food alone I mean
gosh
food is proteins fats carbs calories and
nutrients but is that all it is culture
man it's laughter it's Joy it's hanging
out with your friends your family big
Italian family it's it's everything it's
it's the centerpiece it's connecting
it's I'm depressed it's I'm anxious it's
I'm at the movies so these kinds of
foods yeah it's uh I'm you know
breakfast foods and lunch foods and
dinner foods so to try to simplify diet
all the way down to eat this don't eat
that here's your calories is really
ignoring how we really value food and
what it means to us it's this huge part
of who we are and it's a big part of our
behaviors and if unless we tackle it
that way we're gonna we're gonna fail
and all that look diets have
85 fail rate and this is within the
first year
um you stretch that out to five years I
bet that number gets north of 95 percent
and and that's the other problem we
don't need to figure out new ways of
losing weight we do a good job by the
way losing weight millions of Americans
lose weight every single year we gotta
tackle the real issue which is how do we
keep it up keep it off now what's the
problem why are we all gaining the
weight back
um and I do talk about in the book
um a lot of the reasons why I think
we're getting the weight back so
yesterday A friend of mine
um called This is literally I'm in on
the streets of San Jose take a step out
take a call and they said hey I went to
the doctor and like looked at me and he
mentioned probably five times I need to
lose some weight and we've let him know
that for years just as one of our
friends
and he said he gave me this list of all
these different diets I can try and
whichever ones and he's like so which
one of these
what do I we're at a point now where I
told him I said I don't have a great
answer for other than you got to make
peace with why you eat too much and you
gotta quit drinking and
that wasn't a mechanistic well he told
me to try intermittent fasting he told
me to try a high fats and if that didn't
work then I could probably try a vegan
diet
but you just got to make peace with fire
like
that probably wasn't a great answer for
him just me walking on the street on the
cell phone like
what do you tell somebody that because
that's the person listening to the show
right now right they're an over the road
trucker they just want to be a little
bit better dad they're a busy busy busy
mom whose husband's running around what
do you tell that person who's like there
you gotta you gotta cut about 30 40
pounds yeah you actually gave him good
advice really yeah you never give good
enough yeah that was a great one okay so
you want to know what's funny if you
look at the data long term okay so we
all look at that like how much weight
did they lose in a three-month period
ignore that yep how much weight did they
lose forever that's what we got to look
at if you look at the data the most
effective stress if we were to compare
diets
diets to therapy therapy is more
effective you take someone who's obese
and you haven't see a counselor and they
go to a counselor or a therapist and
they say uh yeah I just have this issue
with food
they'll have more success dude I didn't
that's I don't even know that that's
true now I I as a trainer I figured this
out later on and I would work with my
clients and therapists and my success
rate went through the roof and this is
how I learned this is one of the ways I
learned a lot of my strategies was by
hearing how these therapists would
communicate to these people I'll give
you a great example okay
um most people enter into a diet or a
workout program
from a place of self-hate that's okay I
don't I I look gross I'm not sexy I'm
too skinny I'm too fat whatever okay so
they're going into it from a place of
self-hate
when you hate yourself diet becomes
restriction exercise becomes punishment
so when I used to manage gyms I would
see this all the time people would come
to the gym and they would value the
workout based on how much pain they felt
and how hard they sweat and how sore
they got why it was cathartic because
they had to punish themselves I'm so
overweight I'm gonna go beat myself how
many times have you heard this that's me
man yeah well that's most people you
describing me yeah that's most people
how many times have you heard people say
um oh man I ate so much pizza pizza
yesterday I'm gonna go and just sweat it
out and beat myself up yeah right so
that right it's no wonderful yeah okay
so I'll tell you a story where this
really
where this really
um became it was Illuminating to me this
particular conversation so I was at a
dinner with my ex-wife so she used to
work for tech company and they would
have these like big dinners where you
can meet spouses and whatever and we're
I'm hanging out with all these you know
all her co-workers and their spouses and
we're all introducing ourselves and um
you know as a trainer whenever I
introduce myself
um of course people all of a sudden
become self-aware of like the food
they're eating so you know oh you know
my name's Sal and I you know I own a gym
or whatever of course people are like oh
don't look at me I'll have another glass
of wine don't make fun of me or whatever
so that kind of starts out at first but
then everybody got comfortable and as
the wine started flowing I remember this
lady
singing across from me she goes you know
Sal she goes I had a friend
who you know she was 48 years old
exercise all the time ate right whatever
and then she got cancer and she died and
so I just said you know what I'm just
gonna enjoy my life I'm just gonna enjoy
my life and I'm gonna eat everything and
drink and just you know forget exercise
and I sat there really quiet and you
know I empathize with her and I sat
there and it hit me and I said what a
strange thing to say
that because we know this it's a fact if
you eat right and you exercise the
quality of your life improves
dramatically oh there's almost nothing
that that won't improve if you're
healthier that you're better parent
better employee innovate better more
productive everything right I said gosh
she said she just wants to enjoy her
life so she's not going to do those
things and I've heard that so many times
I thought how can that be
oh I know exercise is a punishment and
diet is restriction it's they go into it
with a self-hate I hate myself they
divide themselves into two different
people
the child that needs to be tyrannized
don't do that don't do this you're gross
whatever and eventually you leave
because why you rebel I don't want to do
this anymore this sucks I don't want to
punish myself I don't restrict myself
I'm a grown-up I can do whatever I want
yeah yeah by the way this is why when
people go off a diet they don't go and
have one cookie oh they have a box of
them in a bag dude yeah they are
rebelling against that in that because
that psychological phenomena that
happens what if people did this instead
what if people went in to diet and
exercise like this instead of looking in
the mirror and says oh I look gross I'm
disgusting I'm gonna go beat myself up
or whatever what if they said you know
what
I haven't been taking care of myself and
I deserve to be taken care of just like
anybody else you know what I'm gonna
start doing I'm gonna start taking care
of myself like somebody I care about and
then they go to the gym and they do what
they train themselves appropriately they
don't overdo it they don't beat the crap
out of themselves they go in there and
the goal is to feel better right what
about diet I get to I don't have to yeah
now the diet is balanced you offer me
that cookie it's I can't have it it's uh
you know I actually don't want it I know
how I know how I don't feel good after
that yes or yeah I'll have that color
I'm all in yeah because you know here's
the thing about health we talk about
this a lot on the show
Health isn't eating you know the right
amount of calories and proteins fats and
carbs and exercising all the time health
is is a is a sphere and it's quite
balanced sometimes healthy eating is you
know hey I haven't seen my friend in in
a year and we're gonna go get some pizza
and have some beer yeah yeah sometimes
that's healthy yeah usually it's not
sometimes it is though right right and
that's how you develop that balance
that's how you have that cookie enough
to eat the whole box and it's not
because you can't it's because that's
what you want and you know if we can get
people and this is what I eventually
figured out how to do is to get people
to develop that relationship with
exercise and diet and then they do it
forever